very interesting news on the cannabis
front
the house of representatives yesterday
passed a law
which would allow banks to provide
services to cannabis companies
in states where it is legal which is a
significant step
towards removing what is a real barrier
to the development
of this industry nationally as we've
talked about before there has been a
major issue within the cannabis
space where even if it is legal
and by legal it could be recreationally
legal
recreationally decriminalized but
medically legal and so that's what the
the
the pot shops essentially are selling
whatever the case
if you have to deal in cash because
banks aren't allowed to work with you
that is a major problem it's a security
problem because people know you have so
much cash around it's a problem in a lot
of different ways
lawmakers voted 321-101 which means
democrats but also some republicans
to approve the bill and send it to the
senate it is unclear what is going to
happen in the senate
but we know that banks have been
generally not willing to do business
with companies that are in this business
because they could be running a foul of
federal laws now i'm aware because i
have friends in the industry
um in let's see in in arizona
in massachusetts and some other states
they've told me that there are
credit unions that operate only within
one state that seem more willing to work
with cannabis dispensaries and other
businesses
and they feel relatively comfortable
that the government is not going to go
after
them i don't know whether that's
actually true or not
i don't know if that's a false sense of
security but this is a really important
thing now where you
you get to a conflict is the banking
industry wants this
and why do they want it well because
it'll be hugely profitable and there is
a contingent of people who are sort of
stuck
between what is seemingly a rock and a
hard place for them where they want
cannabis legalization
but they really are skeptical of the
banking industry so if the banking
industry wants something
their reflexive reaction is to be
against it
um listen banks are going to make money
with this banks are going to make money
with anything
that is you know whether it's ipos of uh
companies that shouldn't be ipo'ing or
holding money for arms deals banks are
going to make money regardless the
question is
do we want to further legitimize this as
an industry so that we can get away from
spending tax money
imprisoning people who either use have
or sell
marijuana and rather collect tax money
from this as a regulated industry and be
able to use that tax money for public
health initiatives for education for
whatever the case may be
i'm of the mindset of i don't want my
tax money going to imprison people
involved in cannabis
i want to see my tax money
uh um uh bolstered
for lack of a better term by tax money
from a legal and regulated cannabis
industry my position is clear
the positions of of the united states as
a country are moving more and more in
that direction this is a big deal
i don't yet know whether we can expect
it to pass the senate we will see
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign
up at privacy.com slash pacman